more unpopular nutrition truth that
Wellness influencers don't want you to
know it is completely normal for your
blood sugars to rise and fall between
meals a completely straight line is an
unnecessary goal
eating soy won't make you grow boobs if
it did I would at least fill my eight
cup
cayenne pepper in your lemon water won't
speed up your metabolism it'll just give
you the runs
a superfood is just a regular food with
super solid PR
leaky gut is an unofficial diagnosis
extrapolated from a real diagnosis
designed to sell you detox BS just
because you can't pronounce an
ingredient doesn't make it toxic not
everyone's confident pronouncing coal
calciferol
if you think you're hungry you probably
need some food not 64 ounces of water
drinking coffee to suppress your hunger
isn't a cool hack it's actually pretty
disordered which of these nutrition
myths are going to make the most
influencers mad now go away because I
gotta drink my coffee in peace